target chairman and ceo brian cornell is
with us now to discuss his diversity
goals and how the company is responding
to high inflation and consumer fears of
recession brian always good to have you
in the studio and bravo to you bravo to
houston white number one from bringing
it to your attention bravo to you for
sitting down and listening many ceos
give it lip service but you certainly
seem to put your money where your mouth
is
this was important to you why yeah well
i've got to start with happy anniversary
this group's been having a lot of fun
this morning thank you
this much fun every morning we do kind
of do we do
much to the chagrin of our control room
well it's great to be here to celebrate
houston white and we're launching his
collection as we speak across the
country but it's a great human
connection story gill and i've i met him
back in 2019 you stand up at a barber
shop in minneapolis
and actually had a meeting there with
about 40 of our black team members from
minneapolis and i spent some time just
talking to them about business about
target about life about sports and then
i had a chance to spend time with
houston afterwards and he wanted to show
me some of the plans he had in place he
had opened up this barber shop he had
plans to open up a coffee shop there
develop some housing adjacent to his
barber shop and then he started to show
me his design plans for apparel
and what was really unique for me was i
saw someone who had a dream a plan but
was focused on execution
and coming out of the pandemic we want
you to come to life and it's just great
to see someone like houston kind of put
together such amazing plans and and
partner with a company like target to
bring his dreams to life
you know one of the things that you that
jamie mentioned in the piece and you
said is you met with you know your black
employees black officers at target in
the wake of george floyd's murder what
was that like for you because i think as
gail pointed out a lot of ceos say that
they want to increase diversity in their
companies but they very rarely ever
interact with anybody who's not like
them because we all sometimes live in
our bubble what was that like for you
well i'll step back so
early on in 2019 i actually spent time
with a group of my black officers we
went to atlanta together and i've been
doing these what i call immersion trips
for five or six years now
bring eight or ten leaders together i
travel with them for a day introduce
them to other ceos
business leaders in the community and we
get to know each other
and in january of 2019 i went to atlanta
with a group of black officers and when
we finished up the session they said
brian there are team members in
minneapolis that would love this
experience i said well let's set it up
and
they said would you go to this barber
shop
in minneapolis and we'll meet with about
40 team members there
so it was houston's barbershop but i had
a chance to just spend time with my
local black team members and just get to
know them understand some of the
challenges they were facing things that
were on their mind but just spend that
time connecting yeah and for me it
actually prepared me for
george foy's murder
because the first thing i did
coming out of that was recognize i had
to connect with my black leaders and i
will always remember gail
having a zoom call
right after george boy's murder
and seeing a screen after screen after
screen on the zoom call
of black leaders with tears in their
eyes talking about the challenges they
have been facing and the tough
conversations they had had with
family members their kids it was a very
painful conversation
but they helped inspire all of us to say
we've got to stand up and do more well
there's nothing like a black barber shop
to go and hear the truth that's true
and speaking of here that hearing the
truth i i want to turn attention to the
economy uh there's a lot of fear of
recession out there you you see
indications of that or you would anyway
as a retailer people go to target for
low prices sure are you seeing
indications that these fears of
recession are not just fears but we're
gonna get one yeah
i wish i could give you the answer and i
really can't right now and i think we're
sitting here in a very unique period of
time i go back to the last time we were
together which was three years ago yeah
i mean since then we've faced a global
pandemic
the u.s economy was locked down yeah
many of us learned how to work from home
and educate family from home
as we started to move through the
pandemic there was trillions of dollars
of stimulus pumped into the economy and
child care credits and then earlier this
year as we're getting back to normal
starting to go out again
warren europe rising fuel prices 40
years high for inflation so right now i
think it's really hard to gauge the
consumer i can tell you how we're
approaching it well you'll get another
three years because target just
announced you're going to be ceo another
three years and i'll go ahead and
announce i'll continue to be a customer
for the next few years
thank you very much